all right before we get started on thank
the sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by raycon
raycon earbuds are those slick stylish
true wireless earbuds that come in at
about half the price of the competition
raycon earbuds offer you six hours of
playtime seamless bluetooth powering
more bass and a more compact design that
gives you a nice noise isolating fit
and they come in a nice variety of
colors patterns fit options so whatever
your style they got you covered no
dangling wires or stems so they're nice
slick discreet and yes they do remain my
workout earbuds because as always
demonstrated they've yet to fall out and
welcome
to the hair show
and raycon has a 45-day free return
policy i personally
i love that kind of faith and product
you know risk-free for the consumers
respect that so click the link below or
go to buyreicon.com
jones to get 15 off your recon order and
thank you once again to raycon for
sponsoring this video as always i really
appreciate it all right wine division
the series finale at least the episode's
called the series finale so i assume
there's not going to be a season 2.
anyhow the last episode of one division
it's out that's a spoiler warning for
the last episode of one division
just so you know as always not a
play-by-play for the episode but just
talking about some things i found
compelling
interesting appealing i'm getting this
episode to you a little later because
well
partly because i was really thinking
about some of the deeper themes in the
show won division that i really
liked also because i binged the entire
show of one division from the beginning
leading up to the finale felt like
that'd be an important thing to do felt
like it was a good thing and i still do
it just lends some perspective it's fun
to see some easter eggs going back maybe
i'll do a video talking about
my thoughts going back to the beginning
and watching one division from the
beginning to end but now this is more or
less talking about
the last episode and in this episode
cat's out of the bag it really is the
confrontation
it's the vision versus the dream and the
witch versus the [ __ ] which is hands
down the least
interesting thing about this episode i
mean right
special effects visual effects fights
cgi fights we've seen him
a hundred times there's even a shot in
here which is pretty sweet when vision
tackles fake vision well i guess he's
not fake vision
he's more real vision than wanda's
created vision for the sake of it since
new terminator vision looks like vision
pre-order dlc skin pack this is totally
what i thought of when i saw him anyway
i was like
that's a pre-order skin for a video game
that's what the they're always white and
gold like it's cooler than the actual
costume anyhow i'm going to call them
dlc vision so when dlc vision was
crushing wanda's head
then vision comes and tackles him and it
totally reminded me of man of stale
because i've seen a man of steel where
calalley tackles zod
he's like stop you attack my mother
though i don't want to downplay that
vision on vision fight that was pretty
sweet in the sense that one vision would
punch at the other
and then one vision would block and the
fist would face through the arm and the
arm would solidify
so then he has a hold of the other
vision's arm it was just
it was unique stuff in that respect it
was a superman fight in which they could
face through each other
but they were always on point it was
just like they were perfect fighters
like watching an evo match it was like
watching the world's best play super
smash brothers or something like i could
not keep up with this everyone's
perfectly attacking perfectly blocking
perfectly countering perfectly
parrying it's just it's a perfect fight
but the vision fight was never as
interesting to me as the vision thought
experiment you know in visions like why
are you attacking me is like
my protocol mandates that i must destroy
the vision divisions like i'm not
technically vision and he's like
i require more information so they talk
about it because it's a thing i always
think about i see that with old vintage
collectible items granted i know nothing
about the restoration process but when
you have someone going yeah this is old
this is vintage this is 200 years old
but this was rusted this was broken this
was busted this was broken so i had to
replace this this that that that
you're like well it sounds more new than
old now
is it still vintage i mean even for us
for you humans
was it every seven to ten years most if
not all of the cells in your body have
been replaced through new cells so
you're not even
physically speaking the same person just
like i mean that's fascinating to me
that's what i like about wand division
there was one episode i talked about
wand division
half the episodes talking about how the
show
makes me think about the perceptions of
reality and i give the mcu that it's
like wanda vision was their first
attempt
not always the smoothest attempt but the
first attempt at tackling
something like that if they ever did
before it was still like yeah but it's
you know it's the mcu movie thing
they're still doing and then
vision touches dlc skin pack vision and
gives him
the memories back of vision so dlc skin
pack vision is going to remember
everything that vision did and had in
his life everything he was
up until when the mind stone was
shattered or no actually it shows the
mind stone shattering
but he'll remember everything up until
the point thanos ripped the stone out of
his head
point is if the soul if what we are is
the aggregate of our memories
then him having those memories that
vision is back i mean he's even
in the same body so yeah his vision
again he just has a new dlc skin pack
which goes to show you in the mcu
no death is permanent less is
quicksilver it seems
pretty final we kind of got quicksilver
back in that mandarin kind of way that
ben kingsley iron man 3 kind of way not
the mcu's thing to like we really want a
shocker here
um it's an actor it's not actually the
character you thought it was
clever yeah i feel like internet's
probably gonna be pissed about that it
definitely isn't the x-men crossover we
thought it was i know i'm skipping
around a bit so agatha harkness's thing
is that when wanda uses magic on her
agatha saps it and then wanda gets like
old witch lady hands but in the previous
episode wanda found out about runes and
she was like i don't cast
runes i don't do any of that i'm not a
witch i'm not this scarlet witch you
speak
of i'm just me apparently 15 minutes
later wanda was like i think i know how
to do rune magic
so she cats were like i like the clever
concept of it this hex
this bubble reality this world's
essentially a contained thing
so if you cast runes on the wall nobody
in there can cast magic except the one
who made the runes
which would be scarlet witch which would
be wanda however i just don't know how
she
learned the magic because she didn't
know how to do it before other than well
they kind of had to have her
know it so there's that it's kind of
funny that she went from not knowing
anything about runes to winning the
fight by casting runes and in the end
when she traps agatha there essentially
and then makes the hex go away
is agatha still there i guess i didn't
think of that when i watched it was zack
at the like
oh gee whiz han and then it all goes
away and
then she's not like that anymore because
she's outside the hex because the hex
doesn't exist she's like
look as wanda didn't think that one
through i'm out
well don't know but there was a
tear-jerking goodbye there you know like
wanda saying bye to her kid she's saying
by division
it's all super sad super heartfelt
gut-wrenching and all that
saying goodbye to her created family
that can't exist outside the hecks
she doesn't know her boyfriend's
actually alive out there in a new dlc
skin suit if you pre-order today but as
interesting as this show
was when it dealt with perceptions and
realities and something i still saw in
here that i'll get to in a second it
still falls into the mcu isms of well
agatha i just don't care about as a
villain she kind of showed up to cause
trouble for wanda because she wanted to
know how wanda got so powerful out of
nowhere so that whole it was agatha
harkness all along song
that song was [ __ ] because it wasn't
it was wanda all along it was agatha all
along just like there was that luke
skywalker
level cameo where was that they were
like oh there's this luke skywalker
style cameo
who nowhere yeah i even watched the post
credit scenes
it's not in there don't give me that
it's the scarlet witch thing now that's
some [ __ ] i always thought the claim
of a luke skywalker style
or level cami i was pretty bold that to
me is like
it's professor x or it's nobody because
who else would it be that's that level
people have been stuck on mephisto for
weeks he's not here theories are still
happening though people are holding on
to that theory they're like but
technically in the post-credits scene so
if mephisto
just probably not it's fine the
mid-credit scene monica rambo runs
across
a scroll and she's like alright so a
friend says uh you've been grounded
let's
let's get the [ __ ] out of here so we're
gonna see more monica rambo
probably in captain marvel 2 or her own
movie but it took
black widow this long so captain marvel
too and the post credit scene when
wanda's like
i'm staying off social media forever and
she's out in the middle of this cabin in
the middle of nowhere so she has the
kettle on
and then it goes to the back of the
house and then scarlet witch is there
reading through this book and then she
hears her kids like help me
so anyhow don't really know what to make
of it
maybe she's doing astral projection but
she's so good at it that it's more
physical or maybe it's just her astral
form no idea point is she's going after
her kids
and maybe the multiverse of madness is
gonna tie into this they said it would
but
they also said that there was some luke
skywalker level cameo so who knows
would have liked to have seen a tie-in
in here but we didn't
get that i mean imagine that post-credit
seems italian i'm just saying a hard
tie-in you know where princess daisy
comes
with a gun she's like mario luigi you're
not gonna believe this
yeah i went there that's a cut but i
will say this
wanda maximoff is absolutely positively
most
definitely one of the most compelling
villains the mcu's ever had
i know the list on that is short but
she's topped here and yeah
she's a villain i'm just saying she is
feels weird to say cause she's wanda we
love her and all that but
you just kind of look at the situation
she is she kept an entire town hostage
mentally enslaved them in a state of
what's called in the show
agony and that all just it really
fascinates me because it does
play into the perceptions of reality and
perspectives something that's
in one division always kind of under the
surface but it's the thing i like most
about wand division it's what i liked
about the finale i didn't care about the
cgi fights i thought they were fine but
it's that concept when it just kind of
hit me i was like
so wanda's a villain she's actually an
[ __ ]
i get that it was out of a state of
agony and she had her whole
best intentions for doing it but so does
every villain every
villain is the hero of their own story
right that's the phrase but i also got
to thinking of the fact that while
i knew that she did that while i'm
watching the whole heartfelt goodbye
i was still invested i was like oh this
is sad this person who tortured an
entire town of people saying goodbye to
her family oh
and i still cared and it's just it's a
fascinating thing
that we as people are
quick we're quick to forgive fictional
characters
and not give that same courtesy to our
real world
fellow human beings you can make the
argument it's because
well they're fictional they didn't
actually do anything but i don't think
that's it i think the reason is because
we've seen their story that's the reason
because we're attached to them and we
know that
the quality of wanda's character
is bigger and deeper than this one thing
she did thing is that fact is true for
real human beings we just don't
see that we don't see their whole story
we just see that part and i know i'm
using a comparison of fictional
characters and real people i'm not
saying the
two are equal i'm saying it just seems
like people have a
concept of people growing past a moment
or being bigger being more than that one
flawed moment
social media wise we people collectively
we apply that understanding to fictional
characters
not real people though we do have that
understanding as
seen in fictional entertainment it's
just i find it interesting
and sad but in the end wanda is more a
villain than director dick is
i mean there's that i'm just it's weird
to say his main goal and focus for the
show was trying to get in there and
free the citizens of this town from the
mind control torture
of wanda maxima so to them he's a hero
to all the citizens of this town
while they're having their ptsd for the
rest of their lives
that they'll most definitely have i
imagine they'll have this guy's
picture above their fireplace and i
think that's the reason
in the show they had director i still
call him director dick
always well but i think that's the
reason they had him shoot at wanda's
kids because if they
didn't do that you can just make the
argument
that though he did some shady stuff he
wasn't wrong and he was just trying to
liberate
a town from physical and mental
captivity and torture
director dick did some shady stuff but
so did tony stark i'm not talking about
when he was an
arms dealer i'm talking about after he
had his moment of enlightenment
years later tony stark recruited a minor
to fight with him at an airport against
super powered individuals
and lied to the kid's legal guardian
about it and where he was taking him
incredible job
your nephew did this weekend at the
stark internship
retreat so what is that kidnapping child
endangerment tony stark should probably
go to jail for that one but no we're all
crying at his funeral no one's gonna cry
at director dick's funeral because
what he's an [ __ ] so it does show how
susceptible we are to having our
perceptions and perspectives of heroes
and villains manipulated you know the
reason i bring all this up is because
there is a social media link
that's there that i'm seeing i don't
even think the show meant to do it
but it's there because in one division
you have heroes and villains and
perceived heroes and villains you have
wanda who's the tragic hero and director
dick who's just
he's gonna go to jail and rot because
he's a villain and we hate him wanda
caused a lot
more damage than director dick did and
on the next adventure she'll definitely
return to the mcu and we'll have her
back and
you know we'll be like oh it's all right
we see director dick again will be like
no there's that guy we're judging them
by how the show has told us to judge
them which shows how easy it is
to weave and forge audience perception
of characters and the reason the
perception of who is a hero and who is a
villain being so easily manipulated by a
narrative concerns me
is because tweeters are the
screenwriters
of the perceived heroes and villains of
life they're the weavers of the
narrative that forges the perceived
moral zeitgeist and when we see it so
easily manipulated it is concerning
anyhow that's the social media link i
said i gotta get out of here before i go
on a 45-minute tangent you didn't come
here to hear this
he came here to hear about wand division
on division i enjoyed it as a whole i
still think the first couple episodes
could have been one episode even in the
second viewing going all the way through
i didn't really care until about the
third episode so
it has a little bit of pacing issues
there agatha harkness is a who gives a
[ __ ] kind of villain
um but wanda is a great villain
compelling villain and it made me think
about villainy and made me think of a
thing i
think of a lot alright so one division
the series and the finale have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you